quel message vous votre propre message à
Israël
en ce moment arrêtez de tuer des enfants
[Musique]
ce n'est pas le moment de chanter ce n'est pas
le moment de
chanter quand tout le monde meurt là-bas
et pleure
il y a des pleurs et des
pleurs et des morts et vous ne pouvez rien y faire,
juste chanter
c'est quelque chose de vraiment grossier et pour
dessiner,
vous ne pouvez pas rester assis dans votre chambre 24 heures sur 24
sans aider quelqu'un
qui est aussi grossier, alors je m'entraîne
juste juste  faire des trucs sur mon téléphone
parce que je veux donner aux autres
quartiers comme l'Amérique et le Canada
ce que nous ressentons ici, donc je pratique
cela
plus que mes deux autres talents,
vous voyez, les enfants ne peuvent même pas manipuler une arme
à feu pour vous tuer alors pourquoi
pourquoi tu les tues ils ne
connaissent même pas leur avenir
il y a des enfants qu'ils tuent
qui ne peuvent même pas te parler